one of the first schools of socialist  thought was utopian socialism which in  itself is sort of an umbrella of  different theories but in this way of  thinking socialists have posed that  capitalists factory owners and others  would voluntarily hand over the means of  production to workers they believed that  this would be accomplished by way of  education and conversations between  socialists and capitalists until all the  means of production were controlled by  the collective and decentralized  democracies  many utopian socialists drew from  christianity to form the rationales for  their views utopian socialism has often  been criticized for focusing too much on  theoretical models of how the socialism  might work and not enough on how it  would be achieved hence the name utopian